hola hola Brady Ola Brady a key L
sequenza
I think that's what sequences in Spanish
the Bernardo recommen who is a club
young Frenchman actually Bernardo if
you're watching he is a teacher in
Colombia and he invented the sequence
called the recommend sequence which has
got all the sequence people crazy
because it's like really interesting and
really fun so it's really much easier to
explain how this works on a number line
okay so just say this is not and this is
one two three four again I'm Evan twelve
thirteen and we go on okay so what we're
gonna do we're gonna go air hops we're
going to start at zero and the first hop
is one and then the next hop is two then
the next hop is three so each iteration
you add one to the hop okay dead easy
and the rule is I pass the mpany always
back but if you can't go back because
the number has already been used then
you got to go forward we start at zero
so then we add one we hop one one I've
got to go to we've got to go backwards
can go backwards to go forwards two
three can we go backwards
one two three no we can't do that
yeah so we gotta go forwards one two
three we got to get to here now four one
two three four yet we can swing here
back there but at five we'll can't go
back so how to get there five one two
three four five yep and go there five
six one two three four five six no can't
do that so gotta go here one two three
four five six okay you can see how
that's gonna go
we're kind of gonna do these little
weave in and out the question is which
is of interest and no one knows is every
number accounted for so will this
ultimately get in every number and it's
been tested up serves like some really
high number but testing it's not the
same as proving it is it it's assumed
that this will this will be the case
yeah yeah cool I think it's cuz you've
got to go back so you're going back and
you're kind of clearing up for yourself
now what's interesting about the
is because it's very very simple you're
just jumping backwards but if you got
you go forward and you get this it's not
chaotic but it is it's ordered for a bit
then it is a little bit not all over the
place then it gets ordered again and
this is easier to see rather than just
looking at numbers this is Julie and our
aliy are you with your eyes or with ears
Edmund Harris the mathematical afters
who I work with a lot has done this
gorgeous representation and to me this
looks like you know in the 1950s and 60s
you would get these artists doing things
that looked a bit like this kind of bit
geometrical but also you got something a
bit human in also it looks like it
should be your wallpaper in Mad Men yeah
definitely it totally could you've got
that mixture of something which is just
a circle you could get more simple than
that and it's got circles of different
sizes and they all fitted together
nicely when you look in there's like a
bit of a mess of how are they joining
there's a bit of chaos
it's standardly beautiful but with a
little bit of the unknown
[Music]
in fact if you saw here this bit here
where it starts off with a loch ness
monster and then doubles back and goes
on you've got that there so the actual
number line is the diagonal along here
well what he's done yeah wherever you're
joined you actually have a proper
semicircle whereas I've just done it
with a sort of I don't know what this is
a kind of human sort of grasping at a
circle or as when you when you do it and
obviously if it's a semicircle the
radius is getting weaker so the bit the
bigger the size that the higher it's
going to be it's kind of getting bigger
but then it gets smaller again but then
he gets bigger and then it has getting
smaller again ya know so we've got the
end there that would be because there
you can't go back and so you'd have to
go on here and it's to keep it nice
within the page looks like about a
hundred that isn't it I'll give a free
book to whoever wants to tell me exactly
where it ends I give him the free book
where it is no they don't even use by
the book they can make a screen grab of
this but the thing is you actually want
to have two of these books because you
want one to color in and like really
than make your own and you want to have
one we have the perfect image by the way
I think Alex means he'll give a free
book to the first person yeah I first
heard about the recommend sequence from
Neil Sloan and Neil Sloat is the guy who
invented he founded who can run the
online cyclopædia of integer sequences
and there I think about 300,000 now
different sequences and I said he give
me some example of sequences that you
really liked and one of the very first
ones that he said was the recomment
sequence and I said why is that they
says because it has this interesting
clash between order and chaos and
actually the best way to discover that
is to listen to it and on the online
encyclopedia there is on each sequence
right although most of the sequences all
the ones that I've looked at there is a
button which press and listen to and if
you want to listen to it you press it so
what it's gonna do is that imagine on
the number line here we've got the
numbers
imagine if this was a scale so that was
the bottom of the scale and then you go
up each one is a semitone gang-up bum BA
bum bum and you've got a sequence of I
think it's six octaves which is the kind
of what make most pianos might have what
you would do is that you would imagine
that the first sort of six doc tape
nurse was sick so that 48 numbers are
these ones going up and then the next 48
go back to the bottom so what you do is
that you are playing the sequence as if
it is a piece of music every number the
sequence comes exactly one next it's not
syncopated it's like bang bang bang bang
bang one two three four five six that's
the world's most boring sequence just
because one to the reverb low what
you're gonna get is the scale doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo at the top dude it's
gonna give him room I go at the bottom
again then Karen getting up really
boring
[Music]
you're gonna do the sequence which is
one two one two one two that's gonna be
done and
[Music]
this interesting sequence and how it
sounds and then we're gonna think why is
that interesting and I have it prepared
here just downloaded it
[Music]
it sounds like someone is playing it and
you've got lots of things going on you
can see at the same time it's going up
but then it's going down then there's a
bit that feels kind of like order we
know where it's going and all of a
sudden just out blue and it's all a bit
discordant
there's no way this cake upper-worlders
going down and it's you know it gives
you the the chills iran's we have like a
horror movie or something that you know
maybe someone's going into a room they
don't know they've got together they've
got to find something and you're
supposed to be feeling nervous and tense
and you'd be listening to that there is
something that feels there's a human
hand behind it but there is no human
hand we've got this incredibly simple
rule which is just back but if you can't
go back go forward and also the
obviously the distances between the
numbers are getting bigger and bigger
and bigger
whether the little twiddle there where
does that come from now if you're
anything like me this video is gonna
have sparked even more questions in your
mind and if that's the kind of person
you are maybe you should check out
today's sponsor brilliant brilliant is a
site full of quizzes and puzzles and
courses all sorts of things that are
gonna make you smarter change the way
you think change the way you attack
problems and everything on brilliant is
guarded by eight principles you can see
them here and there at number eight last
but definitely not least sparks
questions
it says the culmination of a great
education isn't knowing all the answers
it's knowing what to ask and I don't
think there's anything truer than that
if you'd like to go and check out
brilliant I really recommend that I
especially like their kind of puzzle of
the week what have we got this week
there's basic intermediate and advanced
the basic one this week's really fun it
involves its rotating rod and light
being flashed on it I recommend going
and having a look now if you go to
brilliant org slash numberphile you can
sign up with brilliant and get 20% off a
premium membership that means you get
access to all the good stuff 20% off but
just to remind that you can go to
brilliant and look at lots of stuff for
free including the problem of the week
so definitely go and check them out and
then I'd recommend going for the Premium
Membership so you get all the goodies
brilliant org slash numberphile our
thanks to them for supporting this video